this year at Comic Cons gone green
literally we've got the Green Hornet and
Green Lantern which are two of the
biggest Hollywood blockbuster films that
are being touted here but beyond that
the biggest film of them all for this
year's comic-con is Tron the sequel to
the classic now what's interesting about
Tron is that three years ago Disney
actually showed some test footage here
just sort of as a nerd litmus test to
see if the fan base would accept a
remake on the classic and it turns out
that the excitement that it created
three years ago was high enough that the
studio decided to go full on full steam
ahead and do the sequel now they're
still doing post-production Daft Punk is
still finishing the soundtrack but the
buzz here for that film is enormous
there's a Tron cafe there's parties
going on for Tron it seems like
everywhere you turn that's all the
people are talking about so I'm not
gonna lie
Comic Con has turned into a big deal and
because of that there's a lot of
marketing now there's a lot of social
media marketing there's a lot of viral
marketing there's a lot of publicists
and PR flex and you know frankly it can
be a little bit annoying to everywhere
you turn be handed a postcard for
something that you're not that
interested in but on the other hand if
you walk the show floor and you see the
excitement in everyone's eyes who are
dressed up and taking pictures and you
see new artists and new illustrators
that you've never heard of before and
you see old classic comics rubbing up
against new comics you've also never
heard of before so it really is a fun
place to just come and get lost and
frankly I'm ready to go get lost